should say I have real questions about  these platforms like Twitter that  continue to amplify and allow this kind  of hateful language that then plays in  to violence I don't even have much to  say about a Tucker Carlson or anybody  else who lifts up violence and glorifies  violence against the community and then  says hands off when it comes to violence  that actually does happen in that who is  this woman does that woman not realize  does she not have a mirror  Tucker Carlson is not for violence I  have never heard him call for violence  people do say mean things online and  it's very bizarre because for these last  couple years where many people in  mainstream media have called f the  country white supremacists and Nazis  that seems pretty mean it's not that  great if you guys have been doing that  have you been promoting violence against  half the country I get it these people  don't get irony or reality